we're here at the Golden Gate casting
club which is one of the nation's first
casting clubs and we're testing out the
orvis Helios rod this is their new
hotness and it's the lightest fishing
fly fishing rod in the world it's made
from a special unidirectional weave of
carbon fiber that was previously used in
like drones and missiles and expensive
stuff that nobody can ever owned so you
may not think of lightness as anything
that's super important with a fishing
rod but it's really really important
you're standing in the middle of a river
all day casting a nine foot pole back
and forth the light of the rod is the
longer you'll able to fish and also the
lighter it is the more delicate it's
going to be so you're going to be able
to feel a fish on the line a little bit
easier than if it was something that was
harder and stiffer so this rod manages
to have the backbone enough to cast a
really far line but it's also light and
flexible enough that you can really feel
the fish hits so light so I'm in the
Golden Gate casting ponds and we're here
to talk about the wired way to go
fishing now one issue that comes up
continually when you're fishing because
water is the most important part of it
is it everything's got to be water
proofing my waders are waterproof my
boots are waterproof I'm waterproof but
how about your gadgets I mean you're
going to provided you actually catch a
fish you're going to take a picture of
it and that's why you need a camp oh oh
no no problem this is the panasonic
lumix ts1 it's a 12.1 megapixel clearly
waterproof and shockproof camera it's
really good i really like it it's got a
great 28 millimeter wide angle lens and
takes pictures relatively snappily one
problem is it takes a little bit of time
to turn it on so if you think your
buddy's going to catch a fish keep the
camera on it gets pretty good battery
life so it's not really much of a
problem the interesting thing about
fishes at the territorial they camp out
in little spots and they wait for the
food to come to them and it has the the
right combination of river flow and
temperature and food and so if you have
a GPS you can actually mark the spot
where that fish bested you and and then
you can come back to it so you need a
GPS that can do that Garmin's new Oregon
400 T is a really good candidate for
that because it's waterproof in case the
fish pulls you into the water or you're
just a klutz and it's got a really nice
contrast II screen with a really nice 3d
view function that allows you to
actually virtually scoot up and down the
river to see what's coming up around the
bend I wish it had a button that could
allow you to mark a waypoint so you
didn't have to go through a few
different steps on the screen to
actually mark where it is that fish
kicked your ass other than that it's a
great GPS it gets the signal extremely
fast it's rugged its water proof that
comes with a handy little carabiner that
you can use now get onto your belt which
is where it usually lives when I'm
fishing you're fishing you have to bring
a knife with you so Leatherman has been
on this stream lining kick for the past
couple years where they've been taking
products off of their multi tools which
may seem counterintuitive but it's
actually really cool what you need is
een in a knife and you need a pliers and
that is really all this Leatherman
freestyle has a knife and applier you
actually need one other thing a bottle
opener another really important piece of
fishing gear are your sunglasses Zeile
makes this really nice ZX 13 polarizing
system on these swap it tues and that
it's really good because it's not always
sunny and beautiful and these glasses
really excel in their ability to adjust
from highlight to low light they're not
photochromic but the way the tint works
they look really good in highlight and
they look really good in low-light gotta
happen in your line you got to have your
flies you got to have your knife you got
to have your camera so you really need a
good method of storing all this stuff
and that's why this new cloudveil
Windwalker chest pack is a really nice
option it basically kind of works like a
file cabinet the ergonomics of it are
great you can adjust these straps really
really easily on the fly if you need
them you know raise the pack because
you're going in deeper water wouldn't be
as much of an issue of this for
waterproof but it's not I really really
wish the bottom at least was super super
rubberized and waterproof because when
you dip it in the water all the stuff in
the bottom of the pack gets wet you've
got all your gear got a place to put it
you've got your rod 19 is a day off and
severe
you